let's talk about a new generation of
Palestinian Fighters
because some new armed resistance groups
have emerged in the last couple of years
Israel has used massive military
Firepower to go after them and calls
them terrorists we will do what we can
fight the terrorists these groups say
they're fighting for freedom and against
Israel's occupation
so who are these armed groups how have
they come about and what are they
fighting for
okay let's start by looking at Israel's
occupation of Palestinian territory
because it helps to explain what these
new armed groups are resisting against
Israel's occupation has been in place
for 56 years and is considered illegal
under international law Israel enforces
a total blockade on the Gaza Strip and
has ultimate control over the West Bank
even though some areas there are
officially administered by the
Palestinian Authority or the PA and in
the occupied West Bank Israel has built
more and more homes for Israelis known
as settlements they've constructed roads
exclusively for settlers and there's a
huge separation wall
Palestinians need special permits to
travel and Israel has set up hundreds of
checkpoints there's also a constant
presence of Israeli soldiers who
routinely raid Palestinian neighborhoods
demolish homes and arrest people while
Israeli settlers get military protection
settlers have also been behind thousands
of attacks on Palestinian Villages
setting fire to homes and cars
the Israeli occupation itself is a form
of sustained systematic violence right
it is coercive by by Nature the Israeli
Army is there it enforces restrictions
on Palestinian life there's basically
this huge imbalance of power where the
entire weight of the Israeli state and
its military controls pretty much all
aspects of daily life for Palestinians
it's a system that writes groups like
amnesty and Human Rights Watch say is
apartheid where Israeli authorities
methodologically privilege one of the
group's Jewish Israelis while
authorities allocate different baskets
of inferior rights to the other
Palestinians systematically
discriminating against them you can just
see how
people who were who've lived that
reality their whole lives they don't see
a future
over the decades Palestinians have tried
resisting Israel's occupation in
different ways
there have always been methods of
non-violent resistance things like
protests strikes boycotts and campaigns
to build International support for the
Palestinian cause we've tried everything
as Palestinians there is the daily form
of resistance of refusing to accept
what Israel puts ahead of you so for
example checkpoints it would be so easy
for Palestinians to just stay within the
ghettos that Israel has created but
instead Palestinians resist by insisting
on going through those checkpoints
and then of course there's the violent
resistance and that violent resistance
is a resistance that Palestinians have
as a right because there is nobody who
is protecting us it's not surprising
when you look at the history of
resistance that also there is an arms
elements to the resistance occupation
not to justify violence but it's
violence that breeds violence and
there's been a lot of violence according
to the UN more than 6 300 Palestinians
have been killed since 2008 and there
have been more than 400 Israeli military
and civilian fatalities now over the
years armed resistance groups have been
set up and they've usually been linked
to political factions fata for example
is the main party of the Palestinian
Authority and has traditionally been in
favor of negotiating with Israel they
have an armed Wing called the Al-Aqsa
brigades it's a network of Fighters that
emerged in the early 2000s and they've
carried out attacks on Israeli soldiers
and civilians the other main group is
Hamas which is in charge of Gaza it has
a political wing and an armed Wing known
as the alcason brigades which carried
out several suicide bombings in the
early 2000s and is often behind the
Rockets fired from Gaza into Israel
attacks that have killed civilians there
are other armed groups too which have
been around for a while and also have
political links but the new groups that
have recently emerged in the occupied
West Bank aren't aligned with any
particular political faction nor are
they controlled by the Palestinian
Authority the ones you mostly hear about
are lions den which is based in the city
of Nobles and the Janine brigades which
are based in the Janine refugee camp
these newer armed groups also tend to be
smaller and local mainly based in one
town or neighborhood and it's not clear
who's in charge of them or how they're
organized it is sort of an ad hoc
collection of mostly very young male
militants who belong to different
factions who
don't have a kind of Central Command
either in in political or military terms
what we are seeing now is instead of
them being confined to
groups
perform together to try to protect
the camp trying to protect their cities
their towns
foreign
[Music]
so why have these groups emerged now
well one thing to keep in mind is the
general context in the last few years
you've got this breakdown in
israeli-palestinian relations no peace
process to speak of and an Israeli
government that includes far-right
parties pursuing even more Hardline
policies against Palestinians we have
the most extreme government in Israel's
history that is committed to a vision of
Greater Israel and to complete
annexation and subjugation of the
Palestinian population
we hear about further expansion of
settlements which means
is is
and more and more Palestinians are being
evicted from their homes
are stealing my house and if I don't see
it someone else is going to steal it no
no no no
Allah
instead of Israel being held accountable
it's getting worse that's the Israeli
context on the other side you've got the
Palestinian Authority which has become
pretty unpopular it's criticized for
things like corruption and for
cooperating with Israel on security and
intelligence 63 percent of Palestinians
see the PA as a burden rather than an
asset and 77 percent want the president
of the PA mahura bus to resign he took
office in 2005. it was supposed to be a
four-year term but there haven't been
elections since he's now 87 years old
and is seen as increasingly ineffective
and out of touch so people are viewing
this government with a great deal of
only skepticism but anger is so much so
that when members of the government are
going out into the streets they're being
yelled at by ordinary citizens who are
saying what are you doing to protect us
now you have 18 19 year old Palestinians
who are saying enough uh our our parents
and grandparents Generations have failed
and so we need to take matters into our
own hands
[Music]
in the last year groups like Lion's Den
and the Janine brigades have claimed
responsibility for attacks on Israeli
soldiers and civilians mostly in the
occupied territories but also in Israel
and Israel has responded with a huge
amount of force
the Israeli Army has carried out several
raids in places like nabilis and Janine
in early July hundreds of soldiers went
into the Janine refugee camp in a
three-day operation that included drone
strikes and the use of helicopter
gunships Israel says it hit the Janine
brigades HQ 12 Palestinians were killed
hundreds of homes were damaged and so
were the Camp's water electricity and
sewage networks they were literally
dropping bombs
on a refugee camp and destroying the
infrastructure we still hear the same
Mantra about Israel having a right to
defend itself but we don't hear anybody
saying that Palestinians have a right to
defend themselves or that Palestinians
are in need of protection it's a cycle
of violence that's only getting worse in
2022 Israeli forces killed 151
Palestinians in the West Bank
Palestinian armed groups killed 25
Israelis in the occupied territories in
Israel now look at the numbers for 2023
and we're only halfway through the year
all of that feeds into how Palestinians
more broadly feel about the state of
armed resistance right now a recent poll
showed that a majority are in favor of
forming armed groups like The Lion's Den
and 58 percent support a return to Armed
confrontation against Israel to break
what they see as the current deadlock
the goal now should be how do we prevent
more death and destruction you can
pacify by an area with massive violence
and repression but eventually you will
get a new generation of Palestinians who
don't remember that death and
destruction of the previous rebellion
and are prepared to pay the ultimate
price again at the end of the day it's
about the broader conditions that's
brought us to this one if we bring it
back to those new groups of Fighters
remember that we're probably only
talking about a few hundred people
they're just one part of a much bigger
picture but the emergence and growth of
these groups does tell us something
about that picture including the
cumulative impact on Decades of
occupation and the lack of hope that
anything will change anytime soon
check out the full documentary where Al
Jazeera gets access to the Janine
brigades and make sure to subscribe to
this YouTube channel so you can't miss
our next episode of Star here
[Music]